tell me more about the revolt of the
admirals what happened with that so
after world war ii uh the
uh
the
joint chiefs or
there's a there's a huge budget you know
cut i mean
there's nothing's ever happened like
world war ii um
and
world war ii like nothing's ever
happened like the end of world war ii
where you know the military you know the
the us military prior to world war ii
has always had this um
uh sort of cycle where they they they
build up to deal with that with whatever
conflict whether it was the american
civil war or the first world war or the
second world war they they grew from
sort of a nucleus force to this massive
industrial you know uh mobilized you
know military and then after it
they shrink back down to that nucleus
force again so you can rebuild it uh
again later after world war ii um
the us military or the the
the u.s public has finally learned its
lesson we can't
shrink back you can't
be in this industrial or this uh
era of total war and not uh field planes
and massive ships you have to keep a
residual
uh force
afloat and in the air
but there's still you can't continue to
spend what they were spending in world
war ii so the military shrinks
drastically so all of the military
entities are competing for very limited
resources
but
now that uh all of the you know worlds
or all of the
united states enemies have been defeated
um
the the one that still exists is the
soviet union and
planners don't expect that this is going
to be a massive uh naval effort uh the
soviet union at that point doesn't have
a you know a particularly big navy or
anything like that we don't anticipate
that we're ever going to need to uh land
ships in the soviet or land troops on
the soviet union because we have this
you know
huge
presence in in western europe
so
planners in the army and the air force
are
claiming that they need more of the
resources that the navy doesn't need
resources because we're never going to
have amphibious warfare again
it's just just not going to happen
anything that the navy could have done
all the all the troops that the navy
could have transported the air force can
do it with planes
or we're already ashore anyway so uh
take the money from uh the navy uh give
it to the army give it to especially
give it to the air force so the air
force and the and the army um have
convinced uh you know most of the uh the
top decision makers
in the truman administration that
they're going to you know pull money you
know rob from peter to paypal
well the navy
sees this prospect of what
is about to be done to them about to be
done to their service and not only are
they about to lose all of this money
and all this status but they're about to
be sort of de-clawed you know the navy's
not going to be like a force a defensive
warfare force anymore um and the navy
planners are you know they're they're
they're panicking they're not not just
panicking for their their service but
they realize how um how difficult how
complex expeditionary warfare is and
they're doing everything they can to
save their service by saving the service
save the country
um
so
uh they stage essentially stage a coup
they uh um
not a not a not a coup but they uh
the the
they start
leaking pressure or leaking stuff to
newspaper columnist
i talked about merit merit edson read
mike edson he he
resigns from his
commission in the marine corps so he can
get out and start protesting publicly
eventually the clamor gets so bad that
they have to call uh a committee hearing
uh in the house in in congress um and
it's you know for several days uh it's a
it's a big to-do like uh they they bring
in just about every admiral uh every
every famous admiral from world war ii
to to testify in front of congress yeah
i got a list of names here uh
leahy
blandy nimitz halsey spruance kincaid
connolly carney burke
every blue water hero save kelly turner
save kelly turner farragut john paul
jones
um
that is just basically everyone you
could every pipe hitting
naval leader goes in and uh
makes their case